so the history of mdma begins uh in 1912
when it was first synthesized and
patented patented by merck
but uh they didn't do anything at all
until 1927
and merck did some preclinical studies
and animals and
found nothing of interest and they
decided to just shelve the compound this
is
around the time their patent is going to
expire the next we
know of mdma is the army chemical
warfare service mkultra looking for
mind control drugs and then sasha shogun
who was an incredible
chemist he started looking for new
drugs for psychotherapy and for personal
growth and spirituality
and he re-synthesized mdma experimented
with it on himself
and felt that it had incredible
potential
for therapy and so he gave it to leo
zeff
who was the leader of the underground
psychedelic psychotherapy
community from the middle 70s to the
early 80s roughly half a million doses
of mdma were used in therapeutic growth
settings
mostly by people that leo had trained
and it was found to be
useful in a wide variety of conditions
but it leaked out of that community
became sold as ecstasy and this was at
the time of nancy reagan and just say no
and the rise of the drug war again and
so it was clear that it was doomed so
this was an incredible opportunity to
gather support
to prepare for the defense of mdma once
the
drug enforcement administration finally
decided to move against it
it was in dallas at the start club where
ecstasy really became popular mdma
became popular as ecstasy in a dance
club setting
george bush all sorts of people
participated here and this is what
attracted the attention of the dea
so in the summer of 84 dea moved to put
mdma
in schedule 1. they only knew about it
as a party drug they didn't know about
it as a therapy drug
so in 86 i started maps as a nonprofit
maps is the multidisciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
mdma is the most gentle of all the
psychedelics that's why i felt it would
be the first one
to make it through the system